monsieur cela oui merci d'être avec nous
merci lui alors est-ce que vous pouvez
au mois de mai on vous a donné une
mission qui semblait presque impossible
en six mois au moins et peut-être faire
développer des vaccins est ce que
maintenant vous dites vous êtes presque
mission accomplie oui le mot près ce qui
est très important évidemment on en a
fait franchement on a progressé de
manière très satisfaisant très très
rapides sont mettre en péril la sécurité
l'innocuité des vaccins
nous sommes très contents de résultats
actuels avec les vaccins de pfizer et de
moderne
nous sommes aussi satisfait avec les
résultats des vaccins d'astrazeneca quoi
que nous devions nous devrons essayer de
comprendre un peu plus
pourquoi il ya quelques variations dans
la l'efficacité du vaccin en fonction
des les conditions d'utilisation mais
oui nous sommes très satisfaits on sait
maintenant qu'un vaccin est aussi l'on
sait qu'on a pris des bonnes voies dans
la poignée de recherche ainsi que d'un
point de vue du développement de la
manufacture et le prochain défi ce sera
premièrement avoir l'approbation de et
deuxièmement de manière critique
effectuer la distribution et
l'administration du vaccin et une
majorité des américains
le lendemain de l'approbation de la fdf
vous serez prêt à distribuer des
millions de doses de vaccins
donc est-ce à dire que déjà aujourd'hui
il ya dans des entrepôts réfrigérés déjà
combien de doses vous avez déjà de deux
produits
écoutez pour le maintien de favori à peu
près 6 6 millions et demi de doses qui
sont produites actuellement pour le
vaccin vous donnez un peu près deux
millions de doses qui sont produites
mais les le rythme de production au
niveau industriel a été établi ici à la
fin du mois de décembre on aura à peu
près 20 millions de doses chacun des
vaccins
alors avant
l'approbation par le fbi on ne peut pas
transporter le vaccin donc c'est une
minute après l'approbation que les lots
de vaccins par exemple le vaccin de
pfizer commenceront à être distribués et
on va les envoyer directement au travers
de l'utilisation de federal express et
ups par exemple vers les adresses que
chaque état nous aura donné et on a un
certain nombre de doses une certaine
adresse si on a les doses et l'adresse
on va envoyer des vaccins et les vaccins
seront distribués en proportion de la
population de ce qui est vous attendez à
voir le feu vert de la f10 et pour
lequel des candidats vaccins celui de
phase 1 en premier ou celui de modern
art même temps comment vous voyez la
séquence
les deux vaccins vont être vu une
semaine d'intervalle le 10 décembre ce
sera excellent de file probablement
approuvé le 11 et le 17 décembre sur la
revue du vaccin de moderna qui seraient
éventuellement approuvé le 18 sites ou
si tout se passe bien et je crois que
c'est important qu'on fasse ses deux c2
approbation en conséquence même si elles
sont s'il y avait seulement une semaine
entre les deux étant donné qu'on une
semaine malheureusement aujourd'hui aux
états unis et jusque 14 mille morts deux
mille morts par jour donc chaque jour
coûte au lendemain d'une d'un feu vert
éventuelles vous êtes là le raid de
production aussi va s'intensifier et on
sera en mesure de distribuer
combien de doses parlons juste des états
unis là pour simplifier
combien de doses dans un dc10 six mois
de mars par exemple alors écoutez pour
les deux vaccins celui de modern and
father on sera à peu près entre 25 et 30
millions de doses pour chacun pour les
mois de janvier février mars
seulement ce qu'on prévoit c'est que
probablement à la fin du mois de janvier
au début du mois de février
éventuellement deux autres vaccins
seront approuvé le vaccin
johnson johnson qui en fait un vaccin
une dose en une seule injection est le
vaccin d'astrazeneca si on résout toutes
les questions qui sont autour pour
l'instant et là on aura au travers de
ces deux autres vaccins assez de vaccins
pour vacciner entre 50 et 60 millions
personnes par mois en février mars
très rapidement on compte pouvoir
vacciner la totalité de la population
américaine vers le mois de mai ou juin
mai ou juin donc c'est une rapidité
extraordinaire
est ce que quand vous avez accepté cette
mission qui pouvaient je le répète
paraître impossible au tout départ
est ce que vous vous soupçonner que ça
pourrait vraiment dans les faits aller
aussi vite
écoutez si je pensais que ça ne pourrait
absolument pas marché je leur ai jamais
fait mais je pensais que c'était
possible mais extrêmement difficile et
donc mon attitude personnellement ça a
toujours été le cas c'est de dire on
peut passer toute sa vie à décrier
pourquoi quelque chose ne pourrait pas
marcher
c'est pas parce que leurs marchés ce qui
est important c'est quand on pense qu'il
ya une chance qu'elle marche il faut
foncer pour essayer puis bon on risque
de rater mais dans ce cas-ci raté ça
veut dire des millions et des millions
de personnes qui continuent à mourir une
autre vie qui a été complètement
chamboulée
donc j'ai pas n'ai pas beaucoup hésité
malgré le fait que je ne sois pas du
tout un supporter de l'administration
tube l'important était de d'aider la
population américaine et monde étant
donné que ces vaccins doit être
disponible au travers du mans on sait
que monsieur ne chante pas mis
énormément de pression sur le monde
scientifique pour que ça arrive est
tellement qu'il ya une pleine page de
publicité des grandes formations de 5 il
y a quelques mois dix ans mesdames et
messieurs nous n'allons pas mettre sur
le marché un produit qui ne serait pas
de haute qualité dans le wall street
journal on a vu une pleine page est-ce
que vous il vous faisait dans quelle
mesure vous sentiez la pression
personnellement de monsieur chrome dans
votre travail
franchement absolument aucune pression
du président lui même et nous
pressions de la part de la pandémie et
de la part des virus je dirais temps de
les convoyer que chaque fois il y avait
il y avait une va et puis on avait un
petit répit pineuilh est maintenant une
troisième vague donc la pression elle
venait de là franchement moi j'étais
j'avais mis comme condition pour prendre
ce rôle
deux choses 1 c'est qu'on soit en parle
je m'excuse de troupes allemands
français et tous les pouvoirs
nécessaires pour faire votre travail
qu'on puisse prendre les décisions qui
ait pas une démocratie
il fallait qu'on fonce et deuxièmement
on qu'il n'y ait pas d'interférence
politique il n'ya pas eu d'interférence
politique
j'étais complètement opaques à au
discours politique qui se fait à
l'extérieur de la part du président donc
j'ai pas de problème franchement ce qui
m'a un peu plus on paie embêter étaient
des attaques très personnelles de la
part d'autres politiciens que je
trouvais réellement déplacer et samassa
j'ai mis un certain temps à les digérer
je dirais puis et puis voilà vous faites
référence à des politiciens qui ont
laissé entendre que vous étiez quoi dans
de connivence avec monsieur charles
pourra les trouver
non c'était surtout que je faisais ça
pour gagner de l'argent lors qu en fait
j'ai tout laissé tomber
je ne suis pas payé pour ce rôle je le
fais de manière bénévole gémit j'ai mis
mon expérience et mon expertise et mon
énergie à la disposition du pays et du
monde et je trouvais que c'était
vraiment malsain la grande dune utilisé
en tant que que s'il est évidemment le
le vrai le vrai objectif était une
mémoire
oui mais de toute façon vous gars vous
avez très très très bien gagner votre
vie avec vous aviez un emploi très bien
rémunéré vous êtes un personnage parmi
les 50 les plus puissants disait la
revue fortune
compte tenu de ce que vous avez fait
depuis plusieurs années mais je reviens
la vitesse de l'opération il ya des gens
qui ont des craintes quand même docteur
slaoui en disant est ce qu'on va pas
trop vite
est ce que oui bien sûr que c'est une
guerre il ya des gens qui meurent mais
si on va trop vite on n'a pas confiance
au vaccin
comment vous pouvez
sur et les crêtes déjà qu'ils se disent
quand même six mois c'est peut-être
peut-être beaucoup la preuve c'est une
question très importante
deuxièmement je pense que le contexte
politique dans lequel d'autres noms se
sentaient donc et pendant les élections
etc a exacerbé le potentiel des craintes
et de l'absence de confiance
troisièmement la transparence totale
total de tous les résultats de toutes
les activités et le seul moyen qu'on est
pour essayer d'aider les gens à se
convaincre eux mêmes ou à se laisser
convaincre par les personnes dans
lesquelles ils ont confiance que ces
vaccins ont été développées de manière
très rapide non pas parce qu'on a coupé
des choses qui était important de la
faire parce que premièrement on a on a
utilisé des plateformes technologiques
dans lesquelles les investissements été
fait depuis 10 15 ans qui ont permis
d'aller très vite dans les parties de
recherche en amont de la découverte du
vaccin humain le fait qu'on a utilisé
ses plateformes pour essayer de faire un
vaccin contre certains qui étaient
apparues vous rappelez probablement en
asie du sud-est et aussi quand rumeurs
ce qui était apparu dans le moyen-orient
qui sont des vaccins des virus très
semblable au comique 19
donc on a en avait en fait énormément
d'informations qui nous a permis
d'utiliser notre expérience et notre
jugement pour aller très vite dans les
parties en avant d'aller en clinique
par contre dans les aspects de
développement clinique on a fait des
études cliniques plus important plus
grande en nombre de personnes immunisées
que les études requises pour tous les
vaccins qui sont qui sont approuvés
maintenant il ya une différence la
différence c'est qu'on ne peut on ne
connaît pas encore pour ces vaccins la
l'innocuité à très long terme à l'otan
est là va avoir un follower de six mois
ou sept mois mais ça c'est pratiquement
par définition et 2000 personnes qui
meurent par jour
ça c'est le risque qu'on connaît le
risque conceptuel pour lequel nous
n'avons aucune évidence qu'il existe
mais on a pas d'évidence qui n'existe
pas et le risque à très long terme
mais il ya une chose très simple
on a regardé dans les dossiers de la
rivière sur plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont participé
aux études matinale dans les quarante
ans antérieures que 95% je pense qu'on
démonte canon 500d des effets
secondaires importants le sérieux ont
lieu après vaccination après qu'on ait
complété sa vaccination et dans les deux
mois qui suivent le fait qu'en fait dans
les 45 jours qui suivent très le fait
qu'on a terminé sa vaccination
on a déjà ses observations pour les deux
vaccins qui vont être revus
prochainement on n'a pas d'effets
secondaires sérieux pendant ces d'accord
vous n'êtes vous pas tourner les coins
ronds vous et on avait des plateformes
prête qui avait été développé depuis
plusieurs années dont s'est emparé de
ces beaux les deux là est ce que vous
avez jusque là oui espoir que les six
candidats vaccins il a actuellement les
plus connus vont tous aboutir ou
flamands vont peut-être se retrouver
avec trois ou quatre à la fin alors
écoutez évidemment je ne peux pas être
certain retour de résultats finaux mais
en fonction du fait que les premiers
vaccins à 95 % d'efficacité ce qui est
pratiquement une assurance complète
contre l'infection contre la maladie je
pense que les autres vaccins vont être
positif
est-ce qu'ils vont être à 95% ou à 70 ou
80% pour je pense que l'efficacité sera
élevé mais bon chez les autres
prochainement on a beaucoup les belges
mais nous c'est 95 ce qu'on dit mais on
salue les belges quand même vous avez là
un certain nombre d'années dr slaoui en
terminant le canada nous on sait le
premier ministre doit dit au canadien il
ya trois jours nous on devra attendre
que les autres se servent parce qu'on ne
on a pas de capacités de production
canada d'après vous le délai entre ce
que vous allez avoir comme services aux
etats-unis et des pays comme le canada
écoutez je ne le peux pas vous dire ce
que je sais ce qu'est le premier doses
fabriqué sur le sol américain sur un an
pour le public américain
je pense que c'est raisonnable étant
donné comme un fait les investissements
pour le monde mais de se servir en
premier par contre que ce soit pour le
vaccin de pfizer ou les vaccins nnomo
dernier par exemple est certainement aux
citoyens de ces menaces raser les cas il
y à des centres de fabrication qui
fabriquent le vaccin en parallèle en
europe
je ne pense pas qu'il y en ait au canada
je sais qu'il ya aussi une entreprise
canadienne medicago wailly produit le
vaccin dans des plantes et qui
éventuellement pourraient aussi le
gouvernement canadien a acheté 200
millions de doses des différents
candidats décalage comme vous êtes et
vous vous servez en premier est-ce que
les pharmaceutiques en terminant docteur
sa wii vont faire une fortune avec des
prochaines années franchement je ne
pense pas je ne pense pas je pense que
en fait ce virus une fois qu'on est
protégée une fois étonné qu'il ne mute
pas de mener à levante pour la
protection va être protégée à long terme
peut-être faudra-t-il avoir une dose de
deboos tous les cinq ans ou quelque
chose comme ça mais je ne pense pas que
ça sera très souvent donc c'est pas un
très gros marché
par contre le point que je fais c'est
que en fait en un on a la démonstration
que l'écosystème de l'académique des
biotechnologiques et les boîtes
pharmaceutiques ont les capacités qu'il
faut pour effectivement sauver le monde
je suis vraiment content que ce virus
malheureusement qui quitte en train de
ravager la manière dont on vit ne tue
que probablement une personne sur 1000
qui sont infectés quand on pense par
exemple que bollain tu 90% des personnes
qui sont infectées
ça aurait été une catastrophe horrible
mais ce qui est rassurant c'est que nous
avons la connaissance la technologie et
l'infrastructure et l'industrie qui font
ou répondre à ce genre de risque et
malheureusement on continue d'exister
merci vous
jamais monsieur trame de mamie de la
pression personnellement ne m'a appelé
en disant mais qu'est ce que tu
fabriques vite vite vite vu que ça soit
fait avant le 3 novembre avant le vote
ça n'est jamais arrivé ça ce n'est
jamais arrivé il a dit évidemment de
désiste donc de discours j'assume le
docteur moncef slaoui merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé c'est vraiment très
intéressant vous êtes peut-être un des
hommes les plus occupés de la planète
actuellement j'apprécie énormément nos
auditeurs ou téléspectateurs aussi
bientôt et bonne chance pour la suite on
va attendre le 11 décembre
j'ai noté la f10 et pour le premier
vaccin fait sur le feu vert ou non merci
beaucoup merci au revoir